donc le 17 décembre nous avons accepté
la stratégie vaccinale qui a été
présenté au sénat avec elle la
priorisation des bénéficiaires du vaccin
en fonction de leur exposition au risque
de développer une forme grave de la
maladie mais comparer certains de nos
voisins en particulier l'allemagne le
déploiement de la campagne vaccinale a
cependant souffert de lenteur voire de
deux faiblesses qui ont déjà été
identifiés lors de la première vague à
propos des équipements de protection
faiblesse de la chaîne logistique
alors moi j'ai une première question que
je vais évacuer tout de suite et ensuite
je passerai les aux questions suivantes
vous avez eu recours aux cabines
mckinsey pour être conseillé ce qui ne
me pose pas de principes de le problème
de difficultés mais pouvez-vous nous
indiquer quelles ont été les conseils
qui vous a été donné par ce cabinet qui
a été chargé de les mettre en oeuvre au
sein de l'état et dans quel calendrier
est autrement dit ces conseils sont ils
d'ores et déjà appliquée
où sont ils en passe de l'être donc
monsieur le ministre voici la première
question et ensuite nous aurons une
vingtaine de questions
madame la présidente de la commission
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
laissez-moi vous souhaitez d'abord de
mes meilleurs voeux à mon tour en ce
début d'année je me réjouis d'être de
votre devant votre commission et
j'aurais fort évidemment de me ferai
fort de répondre rapidement aux
questions dans cette espèce de des
changes direct que vous soyez et avait
souhaité installer ce qui me va très
bien
le cabinet mckinsey mais avant lui
d'autres cabinets d'ailleurs c'est sur
un système de carrousel qui est mis en
place dans le cadre du soutien de
l'action de l'état par des cabinets
privés c'était extrêmement classique et
c'est le cas en france et partout
ailleurs en europe nous appuie dans la
conduite du projet en lien avec la task
force la force d'action qui est en
charge de mettre en place toute la
stratégie logistique donc le cabinet ne
vous êtes dans la stratégie vaccinale
pratiques opérationnelles dans les
enjeux de logistique mais également dans
les travaux de comparaison de ce qu'on
appelle le benchmark en afrique anglais
international puisque c'est un cabinet
qui a aussi vocation à conseiller
d'autres bien d'autres ministère de la
santé dans l'application de la stratégie
vaccinale dont je les remercie de leur
aide nous avons
tout intérêt à utiliser toutes les
compétences dont nous disposons dans
notre pays qu'elle soit publique ou
privée je vous remercie d'avoir dit que
cela ne vous choquer pas vous-même en
tout cas ça ne me choque absolument pas
et c'est la tradition d'ailleurs de
notre état que de fonctionner ainsi
ça c'est le début mais ma question
c'était surtout quels conseils vous en
était donné et comment sont ils
actuellement appliquée écoutez ce sont
des conseils extrêmement varié avec
beaucoup de travail au contact des par
exemple des 100 hôpitaux pigeot il faut
sans arrêt les appelait les solliciter
pour vérifier que les livraisons de
vaccins de seringue d'aiguilhe se
déroule dans les bonnes conditions il ya
toute la chaîne logistique entre les
plateformes logistiques du flux à les
plateformes du flux b le centre de santé
publique france vraiment c'est du
travail de j'allais dire du travail de
fourmi mais absolument indispensable
concis pratico pratique il n'a pu
absolument pas dans la stratégie
scientifique vaccinale n'ont eu aucune
décision à prendre en matière de public
prioritaire par exemple toutes les
grandes décisions de politiques
publiques relève du mystère la santé re
sur la base de recommandations
d'autorité scientifique indépendante
vous le savez on est vraiment dans le
pur opérationnelle bien alors nous
sommes pas loin de 30 questions monsieur
le rapporteur général
merci au président monsieur le ministre
tous mes peux d'ailleurs vous accompagne
vous le savez et ma question est
relativement bref j'ai pas revenir
longuement sur la stratégie
je lis je bornes simplement à citer
lopez l'opex tki l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques je
le rappelle pour les nouveaux qui
partageait entre députés sénateurs et
qu'ils aient dominé plus tôt par
l'opposition bien présidé par monsieur
villani son vice-président gérard
longuet que dit cet office c'est que la
stratégie surtout depuis qu'elle a été
corrigé
avec notamment l'ouverture de la
vaccination aux soignants est une
stratégie qui les satisfait qui est
satisfaisante
gérard longuet a bien ajouté a même
ajouté êtes vous sûr que ceux qui ne
sont pas au gouvernement aurait été
forcément plus malin que ce qu'ils sont
mais ma question ce n'est pas d'en
rajouter à ce sujet mais plutôt de vous
poser une question qui nous préoccupe
tous maintenant que la stratégie est en
place s'agit d'avoir un planning de
vaccination
on connaît on a tous vu effectivement et
vous avez évoqué effectivement plusieurs
fois les différents vaccins qui vont
normalement approvisionnées
effectivement les hôpitaux et les
centres de vaccination est ce
qu'aujourd'hui
compte-tenu d'ouverture dès demain au
plus de 75 ans de la vaccination ils
sont neuf une 9 millions en france de 75
ans est ce que vous êtes certain qu'il
va pas y avoir un bug on sent très
nettement aujourd'hui que la population
a envie d'être vacciné beaucoup plus
qu'il n'y a simplement vie jours est ce
que vous êtes en mesure de nous garantir
que pour pâques tous les plus de 75 ans
qui le souhaiteront pourront être
vaccinés merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur général d'avoir rappelé la
vie de l'opex qui a fait un très gros
travail et auxquels nous avons participé
humblement côté gouvernement en terme de
l'audition et d'apports de documents et
la ville au texte compte beaucoup pour
moi en tout cas elle est extrêmement
précieux
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
rapporteur général nous ouvrons
effectivement la vaccination à 5
millions de personnes deux français âgés
de 75 ans et plus ils sont 5 millions et
nous donnons évidemment plusieurs
semaines pour pouvoir aller vacciner
puisque nous n'avons pas à date et vous
le savez 5 millions de vaccins en coffre
ou en congélateur plus tôt nous
disposons d'un million de vaccins 500000
sont livrés entre cet après midi demain
supplémentaires ce qui porte à 1 million
et demi mais incluant les cibles
prioritaires dans les ehpad
mais également les soignants de 50 ans
et plus
donc le rythme des livraisons va
s'accroître semaine après semaine ils
étaient hebdomadaire et donc nous
prévoyons une vaccination qui prendra
plusieurs semaines de la même manière ce
n'est pas parce que nous ouvrons jeudi
la possibilité pour les personnes qui le
souhaitent de prendre rendez-vous en
ligne ou par téléphone que tout le monde
aura immédiatement un rendez vous dans
les prochains jours et c'est je crois
que c'est fondamental de le dire ouvrir
l'accès à la vaccination pour les
personnes de 75 ans et plus en ville ça
ne veut pas dire vacciner tout le monde
d'un coup et donc ce sera les îles et
des milliers de professionnels de santé
qui ont mobilisé des centaines de
centres de vaccination qui sont
opérationnelles sur tout le territoire
national j'imagine qu'on y reviendra
tout à l'heure donc ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas le d'éléments freinant et nous
vaccinerons au maximum de nos capacités
maximum de personnes cela prendra
effectivement du temps j'espère que pour
pâques oui nous aurons terminé de
vacciner en tout cas d'avoir proposer la
vaccination à ses cinq millions de
personnes et même que nous aurons
commencé à proposer la vaccination à
d'autres français par tranche d'âge
toujours vous le savez cela dépendra
également de la validation ou non mais
j'espère de la validation par les
autorités sanitaires européennes
d'autres vaccins à venir dont nous
pourrions disposer en quantité plus
importante
je ne vais en citer qu'un qu'est le
vaccin astrazeneca par exemple qui s'il
était validé d'ici à février nous
permettrait de renforcer nos stocks de 3
millions pour février puis de 6 millions
supplémentaires en mars puis à nouveau
de 4 millions pour avril etc etc
donc nous avons potentiellement 77
millions de doses de livrer avant la fin
du mois de juin pour la france 77
millions de doses vous imaginez donc la
proposition vaccinale que cela
représente pour six mois ce sera une
montée en puissance progressive qui ne
doit rien à la logistique je le dis ici
mais aux commandes qui ont été passées
par la commission européenne depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant et qui nous
seront livrés progressivement très bien
corinne imbert
merci la présidente monsieur ministre
merci d'être au sénat cet après midi
alors après les différentes pénurie
rencontrés depuis bientôt un an nous
voyons bien votre soucis et vous venez
de le dire par rapport aux doses
commandées votre souci de gérer le fût
de vaccins livrés sur le territoire
national afin justement ne pas avoir
une pénurie supplémentaires je rêve que
trois points avec vous une fois ont
constitué le vaccin de chez pfizer
biotech présente un volume de 2,25 me
limite je vous ferai pas le petit
exercice de calcul que vous connaissez
le laboratoire disait qu'on pouvait
utiliser cinq doses par flacon vous avez
autorisé l'utilisation d'une sixième dos
ce week-end puisque en fait le flacon
contient cette dose et demi et c'est une
bonne chose parce que s'ils osent le 2 5
cm 1 % de patients potentiellement
vacciner suppléant en plus
sachant que cette dose prélevées au lieu
de 5 ça ferait 40 % de patients plus
pourquoi ne pas autoriser la 7e dose
prélevés pour gratiner plus de patients
avec un même flacon reconstituer autre
autre question les laboratoires affirme
dans le document qu'il a publié début
décembre 1 le 8 décembre qu'il ne
dispose d'aucune donnée sur
l'interchangeabilité du vaccin de chez
pfizer avec d'autres vaccins contre
lacko vite 19
avez vous à ce jour une réponse à cette
question de l'interchangeabilité et puis
enfin quelle place pensez vous donner
aux différents professionnels de santé
de ville
médecins infirmiers biologistes
pharmaciens dans cette campagne de
vaccination qui prendra qui va aller
vers les personnes de plus de 75 ans
parce que je ne suis pas sûr que la
réponse d'un centre de vaccination pour
les personnes de plus de 75 ans tels
qu'ils vont être mis en place dans les
départements à partir de la semaine
prochaine soit l'unique réponse à
apporter parce que les personnes de plus
de 75 ans à domicile qui ne pourront pas
et placé donc comment vous envisagez
d'associer les professionnels de ville
dans cette campagne de vaccination dans
une logique de proximité
ça faisait trois questions ça trois
réponses rapides mais les sénatrices que
je sache la 6e 12 effectivement été
autorisé par l'agencé du médicament
européenne c'est tant mieux mais même
sans attendre l'autorisation les
problèmes de santé qui s'était rendu
compte qu'il y avait la possibilité de
prélever une sixième dose l'avais fait
je vous rassure
cette dose
la sénatrice ce serait vraiment une
absolument exceptionnel de tous les
retours que nous avons des pratiques
française européenne et même mondiale
certains ont fait état de certains
flacons dans lesquelles il y avait même
une septième dose ce n'est absolument
pas la règle je vous que je vous assure
là dessus et là c'est d'ailleurs parce
que s'il y avait sept dos ce serait
formidable
on gagnerait fekih moi comme vous l'avez
dit 40% l'interchangeabilité non la
personne qui recevra un vaccin en
première injection recevra le même
vaccin lors de son rappel vaccinal
c'était important
et puis sur la prise en charge sont
plutôt l'organisation de la vaccination
pour les personnes âgées isolées et bien
c'est au territoire qu'il revient de
s'organiser
alors là je suis très vivant d'un en la
matière et je me suis entretenu avec les
associations d'élus pas plus tard que en
début d'après midi il y avait là et reif
l'adf la mf france urbaine et je me
constatés sur les territoires d'ailleurs
que déjà l'innovation avait été mise en
place des binômes se sont constitués
médecins infirmiers pour les vacciner
des personnes âgées des collectivités
m'ont dit monsieur le ministre est ce
qu'on a le droit de prévoir d'organiser
le transport individuel ou collectif de
personnes âgées isolées qu'on connaît
qu'on a identifié dans notre fichier
canicule et on sait qu'elles ne pourront
pas se déplacer dans des centres pour
les amener à se faire vacciner
évidemment évidemment évidemment c'est
du bon sens et le bon sens doit
prévaloir
donc nous faisons appel à toutes les
bonnes volontés ce que je dis aux
représentants des élus depuis plusieurs
semaines et je leur fais confiance et je
sais qu'ils sont extrêmement mobilisés
aux côtés des professionnels même
d'autres modalités
j'ai cité tout à l'heure l'exemple
grenoblois un exemple qui est magnifique
les gangs grenoblois c'est la plus belle
ville du monde comme chacun sait madame
la sénatrice
mais plus sérieusement avec lui en lien
avec le conseil de l'ordre des médecins
ils organisaient une vaccination en
soirée avec des créneaux horaires après
18 heures jusque très tard le soir pour
les libéraux qui travaille toute la
journée et qui ne pouvait pas s'arrêter
de travailler pour les servic signer
donc toutes les innovations seront
bonnes
il faut absolument soutenir les
personnes âgées et enfin la quatrième
question qui était caché dans la
troisième à laquelle répond néanmoins
qui est oui nous voulons compter sur
tous les professionnels de santé pour
vacciner qu'ils soient étudiants ou
retraités c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
un décret autorise cela et demain
lorsque nous aurons des vaccins plus
simple qui ne se stocke pas dans des
congélateurs à -70 qui ne sont pas à
utiliser dans les quatre ou cinq jours
et qui peuvent voyager plus de 12
sans casser des brins dahirel lorsqu'ils
voudront ces vaccins plus simple
j'espère vivement que nous pourrons nous
appuyer sur le réseau des officines de
wismes des médecins libéraux des
infirmiers de tous les soignants qui
peuvent vacciner on sait faire dans
notre pays on a le savoir-faire pour la
grippe on vaccine 5 millions de français
en une semaine
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on n'y arrive
pas avec un vaccin qui serrait
d'utilisation identiques
merci monsieur ministre bernard jomier
merci à madame la présidente je voudrais
revenir sur la question du calendrier
parce que l essentiel la stratégie
vaccinale on en a débattu le 17 décembre
dans l'hémicycle et d'ailleurs vous avez
recueilli un large soutien
je dois dire de l'hémicycle à cette
stratégie qui consiste à cibler d'abord
les personnes vulnérables celles qui ce
qui risque de saturer le système
hospitalier et leurs animations qui
risquent de mourir du coc vide pour en
mettant à l'abri ces personnes à la fois
sauver des vies et permettent à notre
société de reprendre ses activités ses
14 à 15 millions de personnes et
comprenez qu'on ait un doute sur le
calendrier de protection de ces
personnes
le premier calendrier qui a été indiqué
au mois de novembre décembre dans les
documents de la has et autres visées la
mise à l'abri la vie reclaque six
nations de ces personnes au premier
trimestre puis la de la campagne a
démarré très lentement et donc on s'est
dit ça ne va pas être possible ça va pas
être le premier trimestre là vous venez
de nous dire qu'on aurait au premier
semestre
77 millions de doses il en faut 25 à 30
simplement pour vacciner ces personnes
vulnérables donc ma première question
c'est sur le calendrier
est ce que ces 14 ou 15 millions de
personnes vulnérables seront vaccinés à
votre avis à la fin du premier trimestre
ou plutôt pendant le second trimestre
c'est très important parce que ça dit à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
en gros le calendrier de faim ou de
régression des mesures de restriction
d'activité est ma deuxième question si
on à 77 millions de doses on dépasse
largement la vaccination des personnes
vulnérables
est ce que dans une seconde étape une
fois que l'on aura mis à l'abri ces
personnes par la vaccination
vous comptez promouvoir une stratégie
non plus de vivre avec le virus mais
d'élimination du virus par la
vaccination d'une fraction beaucoup plus
importante de la population
et si oui à quelle échéance je remercie
monsieur le sénateur vous avez
parfaitement raison nous nous visons à
protéger et à vacciner le maximum de
personnes dans le temps le plus court
possible parce que c'est un moyen de
lutter avec efficacité contre cette
pandémie de protéger les populations et
de retrouver le cours de notre vie nous
faisons le choix de protéger en priorité
les personnes qui sont les plus fragiles
face au virus vous l'avez dit vous-même
et donc je suis ce qu'on appelle des
cibles prioritaires le mot est assez
vilain le mode aussi bon en tout cas les
publics à protéger de façon prioritaire
il est des zones d'incertitude qui ne
sont pas de nature politique qui sont de
nature scientifique par exemple est-ce
que le vaccin astrazeneca sera validée
par les autorités européennes
s'il laisse que c'est fin janvier
puisque c'est fin février
est-ce que c'est fin mars s'il est est
ce que ce sera décidé à un public âgé ou
est ce que c'est pour un public plutôt
jeune je n'ai pas les réponses à ces
questions
imaginons que fin janvier astrazeneca
soit validé pour les gens en dessous de
65 ans forcément nous aurions alors deux
circuits parallèles un circuit
prioritaire avec les vaccins destinés
aux personnes âgées qui leur seraient
pleinement destinée toujours pour les
protéger mais en même temps le démarrage
d'une campagne de vaccination de
personnes plus jeunes moins à risque
avec un vaccin qui leur seraient
réservés
du fait qu'ils ne seraient pas
appliquées pour les publics les plus les
plus fragiles vous comprenez je n'ai pas
la réponse à ces questions puisque elle
relève des du verdict des autorités
sanitaires européennes mais vous
confirmer que si tous les vaccins que
nous avons achetés sont validées en
temps et en heure par les autorités
sanitaires
nous aurions alors neuf millions de
vaccins livrés à la fin du mois de
février 21 millions de vaccins livrés à
la fin du mois de mars
si nous avons 21 millions de vaccins ça
veut dire que nous aurons pu démarrer la
vaccination d'une dizaine de millions de
français voire pas très loin des 15 dont
vous parlez potentiellement et initier
la seconde dose du public avait commencé
à être vaccinés mais cela dépend encore
une fois ni du ministre de la centaine
il prit dans la république ni la
commission européenne et de l' agence du
médicament européen qui doit nous dire
si oui ou non ces vaccins sont
utilisables dans les délais que nous
espérons les plus courts possibles
voilà j'espère avoir été clair cette
stratégie il est totalement lié à cela
et nous
et pardon et la seconde question
l'objectif c'est de vacciner un maximum
de personnes d'éliminer évidemment
d'éliminer la circulation du virus à
voir cette forme d'immunité collectif
mais un nouveau jeu mais quand même une
réserve parce que vous savez que je ne
fais jamais de prédiction et que je ne
vais jamais au delà si je vous disais
mes espérances
on pourrait les partager ensemble mais
mes espérances ne compte pas je sais ce
que je ne sais pas aussi à date et je ne
sais pas à date
ces vaccins ou d'autres préserve de la
contamination s'il préserve uniquement
des formes graves j'ai des raisons
d'espérer
monsieur le sénateur et je sais que vous
êtes médecin et érudit que vous regardez
les études scientifiques et donc vous
savez comme moi que le modern a donc le
passeur n'y a pas de raison qu'il y ait
un mécanisme différent commence à
montrer des signes de réduction des
contaminations
ce qui serait une formidable nouvelle ce
qui serait une formidable nouvelle
ce serait alors l'occasion l'opportunité
pour l'homme de reprendre le contrôle
sur un environnement devenu hostile
olivier henno
oui merci monsieur le ministre merci
madame la présidente vous avez répondu
sur le volume des doses
donc je vais préciser ma ma question la
vitesse de livraison du volume des doses
est-ce qu'elle dépend uniquement de la
capacité de production des laboratoires
ou est-ce qu'elle dépend aussi du prix
des vaccins qui est extrêmement variable
d'un vaccin à un autre sachant que c'est
la commission européenne qui a fait les
commandes vous nous l'avez indiqué jour
merci je vais utiliser une expression
populaire on ne met pas tous nos oeufs
dans le même panier
et lorsque les commandes ont été passées
avant l'été dernier par la commission
européenne
c'était des commandes virtuelles auprès
de laboratoires qui commençait à avancer
sur le chemin de la découverte d'un
vaccin sans que nous disposions des - de
donner à la vague à la vague
certains pays ont fait le choix
d'ailleurs de ne commander qu'un seul
vaccin géosites un pays enfin pour les
pointer du doigt et c'est tout à fait
leur droit mais on l'a souvent cité en
exemple l'accord et la corée n'acheter
que de la stratégie car ils n'ont pas
acheté de files heures savez vous
combien de coréens ont été vaccinées à
ce jour aucun la campagne vaccinale n'a
pas commencé elle ne commencera pas
avant la fin du mois prochain très
probablement
c'est leur choix mais ils on a eu un
atout en france détrompez vous il y a
des cas qui augmente encore et
l'épidémie
l'espagne joue pour pointer du doigt
nous on a eu une chance en france c'est
que nous ne sommes pas un et 27
et quand nous avons mis en place un
consortium de quatre pays l'italie
l'allemagne les pays bas et la france et
que nous avons commencé à
contractualiser avec des laboratoires
lors vous vous avez un vaccin qui
pourrait nous intéresser
on voudrait vous en achetez vous qu'ils
ont commandé la commission européenne
nous a dit laissez nous faire on va
prendre entre guillemets cet enjeu là on
va précommandée à l'échelle européenne
ça nous permet d'acheter par centaines
de millions de doses et donc de fait de
devenir prioritaires par rapport à
d'autres états je ne sais pas si c'est
si c'est bien ou non en tous les cas sa
garantie à l'europe de disposer de plus
de doses cadenas d'habitants et surtout
d'avoir pu diversifier ses commandes
auprès des principaux laboratoires
disposant d'une à mm ou dont on espère
qu'elle disposera d'une m
donc le prix qui voulait il a été le
reflet de cette capacité cette puissance
à négocier des fortes doses d'autres
pays ont fait le choix de se lancer dans
l'aventuré avec un seul laboratoire
certains avec succès pourrait citer
israël d'autres pays ont fait des choix
de se lancer dans l'aventuré qu'un seul
laboratoire et ne sont pas près de
commencer la vaccination
rené paul savary oui merci mais monsieur
le ministre parce que les les gens
s'impatientent et donc ce que je voulais
savoir c'est j'ai appris ce matin dans
le journal local que la livraison au chu
de reims
alertés des vaccins à modern hommes et
qui allait remplacer la livraison des
vaccins finder donc je voulais savoir si
c'était en complément ou pas et surtout
une question qui me préoccupe
chers confrères c'est le passage à six
semaines de la deuxième vaccination lieu
de trois semaines sur quelles bases
scientifiques vous fondez-vous pour
avancer ce décalage aux premières
questions trouvent une réponse simple
c'est en complément monsieur le sénateur
et se voyait ça plutôt comme un geste
fait à destination des communes des
villes des territoires dans lesquels le
virus circule beaucoup des territoires
notamment du grand est mais aussi de
bourgogne franche comté et puis nice
nous avons décidé de déployer les
cinquante mille premières doses de
vaccin moderna en plus en plus des
livraisons de pfizer et pas au lieu de
cinquante mille vaccin si on avait fait
un dispatching national ça n'aurait pas
eu de sens donc il fallait nous
concentrer nous concentrons nos forces
là où le virus circule le plus pour
protéger le plus vite possible les
personnes fragiles dans ces territoires
je pense que vous en serez satisfait
après avoir entendu ma réponse sur la
question de la deuxième injection ça
c'est une question qui est qui est tout
à fait intéressante vous savez que nous
avons laboratoires ont dit la deuxième
injection pour le pactole freezer se
fait entre 21 et 28 jours donc on peut
le faire à quatre semaines après la
première injection
mais l'agencé du médicament européenne
dans ses recommandations a dit on peut
aussi pousser jusqu'à 42 jours parce
qu'on n'a pas de raison de penser que ce
soit moins efficace
l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament dont on dit souvent qu'elle
est frileuse et très attentive et settat
et de fait n'est pas frileuse mais très
attentive caddie dans un certain nombre
de situations c'est pas gênant si on
utilise la deuxième injection jusqu'à 42
jours au lieu d'en servir six semaines
au lieu de quatre semaines certains pays
l'ont déjà entériné de manière en
routine je pense au canada par exemple
je pense également au danemark
l'angleterre elle a fait un choix de
repousser la deuxième dose même beaucoup
plus loin que cela jusqu'à 12 semaines
je crois de mémoire et donc il ya une
saisine de la haute autorité de santé
une saisine de la haute autorité de
santé qui doit nous dire si de son côté
elle estime que cette cette pratique qui
consisterait à différer de quatre à six
semaines à deuxième injection est une
pratique qu'il faut entériner en règle
régulière ou est ce que c'est une
pratique qui peut être proposé dans
certaines situations
c'est là toute la différence j'ai besoin
de l'avis définitif de cette autorité
sachez néanmoins que s'agissant des
ehpad genou désert ont fait le choix de
conserver le rythme de livraison de la
deuxième dose trois semaines après la
première sur dur même pas quatre
semaines mais trois semaines mais je
redis dans la vie de l' agence du
médicament européenne il nous dit que 3
4 à 6 semaines après la première
affection peut être réalisé la seconde
sur les bases monsieur le sénateur des
analyses des datas scientifique des
études qui ont été faites des réactions
et des effets enregistrés chez les
patients qui ont reçu ce vaccin à trois
quatre ou six semaines s'il agence du
médicament european t-il agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
française si de la direction générale de
la santé
et si un certain nombre d'états ont déjà
pris le parti de passer à six semaines
c'est que
vraisemblablement l'analyse scientifique
des données je n'en ai pas la compétence
comme ministre a montré que c'était
possible
oui enfin il n'est pas l'arrêt que nous
adoptons à ce stade j'ai dit que c'était
j'ai dit que c'était possible mais ce
n'est pas la pratique
je n'essaye mais il ya déjà des cas où
on a des cas de gens qui se sont fait
vacciner dans la salle et à qui on a dit
vous revenez dans six semaines c'est une
possibilité
la présidente de commission qui est
conférée il y à une pré il ya deux
possibilités qui est conférée je vous le
redis s'agissant des ehpad par exemple
c'est trois semaines après la première
injection corelio la seconde et ensuite
la pratique permet de passer de 4 5 ou 6
semaines et nous verrons ce que dira la
haute autorité sortie à savoir être qui
nous dit pas c'est systématiquement à
six semaines
ou est-ce que c'est réservé à des
situations soula sous la décision locale
égale qui on a donné rendez-vous ainsi
semaine ne font pas partie des pad mais
ça a été dit ça a été six semaines au
voilà avons écouté on verra à l'esa
christiane bonfanti dossat monsieur le
ministre
parmi les critiques les plus fréquentes
à l'encontre de la stratégie vaccinale
on relève la seule prise en compte des
critères éthiques et sanitaires au
détriment des aspects logistiques
d'ailleurs alain fischer a déclaré il
n'ya pas longtemps et il a confié qu'il
n'était pas du tout spécialiste de ces
questions ni l'organisation ni de
transport ni de livraison et mon
département du lot-et-garonne n'échappe
pas à ces difficultés identifiées à
l'échelle nationale alors vous m'avez
rassurer tout à l'heure lorsque vous
avez dit que les élus locaux seraient
maintenant concernés c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais mon territoire
à l'image du reste de la france restent
insatisfaits désemparés devant
l'impréparation qui caresse caractérise
de la stratégie de vaccination des
français et nous avons à cet effet des
réunions avec le préfet une fois par
semaine et celle que nous avons eue hier
matin n'était pas très optimale le
lot-et-garonne à la spécificité de faire
face à une double difficulté
en l'état actuel des choses les doses de
vaccin demeure insuffisante si bien que
les congélateurs prêt à recevoir les
injections
reste majoritairement vides alors en
admettant que l'état remplisse
pleinement son rôle et puissent
s'approvisionner mon territoire au
rapidement une difficulté plus
structurelles se poserait alors qui va
vacciner le lot-et-garonne comme
beaucoup d'autres départements français
compte des déserts médicaux et plus
généralement une tension élevée entre
offre et demande
les médecins généralistes sont déjà
saturés par la demande des soins
est-ce qu'ils auront assez de temps pour
libérer pour vacciner leurs patients
vous venez de dire et j'en suis ravi que
les médecins généralistes retraités pour
homme pour homme aussi vacciner c'était
la demande faite par le conseil de
l'ordre du lot-et-garonne mais avez vous
envisagé des solutions annexes pour
fluidifier la vaccination dans les
territoires ruraux
je vous assure nous connaissons des
difficultés majeures
merci monsieur merci madame bonfanti
féminisme sénatrice la ruralité fait
tellement partie de nos priorités que
j'ai fait un choix qui est un choix
différent de celui de nos voisins qui de
ne pas prendre de ne pas aller vers 50
vaccinodromes à l'échelle du pays mais à
des centaines de petits centres de
vaccination à l'échelle des territoires
avec je le redis à terme 5 à 7 centres
de vaccination par département jeudi à
terme certains départements ont déjà
dépassé allègrement le quota fixé à 6 en
tout sept centres et j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire au préfet et aux directions
générales de rs que plusieurs centres
c'est parce qu'il ya plus de 100 qu'il y
aura plus de vaccins alloués aux
départements et si je me permettais
madame la sénatrice
je reçois déjà des demandes d'élus qui
me disent je veux plus de vaccins pour
mon territoire
je veux je le dis tout net mehamha
scénariste la répartition des vaccins
par territoire elle est donnée de façon
hebdomadaire après concertation avec les
équipes sanitaires en fonction des
besoins et en faisant une juste
répartition à l'échelle de la nation des
vaccins dont nous disposons à mesure que
nous en disposons et ce n'est pas parce
qu'un élu me dira j'ai pas assez de
vaccins dans mon congélateur il m'en
faut plus qu'on va en enlever en
départements voisins pour lui redonner
aux siens vous le comprendrez ce qui
n'empêche pas mon téléphone de
fumer ou presque certains jours sous le
coup des demandes des élus d'avoir un
maximum de vaccin ce qui est une
démarche compréhensible ce qui montre
aussi que les élus sont très mobilisés
et je m'en félicite
j'étais pas dans le lot-et-garonne
madame la sénatrice mais j'étais à
tarbes samedi dernier avec le premier
ministre et j'ai vu un maire un
président de département et présidente
de région mobilise et mettant en place
déjà des équipes notamment l'équipe
soignante du des équipes départementales
pour elle venir en aide aux et pas de
recul et des élus mobilisés qui ont
développé des centres de vaccination ils
des médecins libéraux des infirmières
des médecins de ville les choses les
choses se déroulent bien avec
l'engagement de chacun je crois vraiment
que tout le monde a sa place et que nous
ne fixons aucune limite dans la capacité
des élus à agir pour fluidifier les
choses et organiser les centres de
vaccination je crois profondément que
c'est la clé du succès et je crois que
ça va dans le sens d'ailleurs de ce que
vous m'aviez demandé lors du débat
parlementaire pour préciser trois
centres de vaccination si j'ai annoncé
que l'objectif c'était qu'il y ait un
centre par département la semaine
dernière trois centres par département à
la fin de cette semaine et jusqu'à six
centres à la fin du mois par département
nous sommes déjà à plus de 200 centres
ouverts le mardi de la deuxième semaine
je n'ai pas peur de manquer de centre
j'ai plutôt la crainte qu'il se
développe un peu trop et que ça fasse
autant de centres qui se répartissent
des doses de vaccins qui dans les
premiers temps ne permettront pas à
chaque centre de tenir toute une semaine
avant la prochaine livraison ce pourquoi
j'attire votre attention président milan
président milan oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur ministre l'ensemble
de nos collègues à juste raison est
intéressé par la protection de la
population
donc moi je ne vous posera pas de
questions sur ce sujet puisque tout est
question sont déjà posés ou quasiment
tout
je vais vous poser une question sur la
protection d'environnement c'est à dire
dans le cadre de la stratégie vaccinale
quelles sont les recommandations qui ont
été mises en place
quant à la collecte et au traitement des
déchets six consécutifs à la vaccination
eh bien figurez-vous on nous reproche
parfois monsieur le sénateur pas vous
mais ça arrive d'envoyer des documents
copieux faille aux autres pour justement
mettre établir un certain nombre de
règles de bonnes pratiques et où qu'il
existe un document un cahier des charges
qui a été envoyée au préfet aux ars et
qui est oui bien sûr seront productifs
pour chaque centre de vaccination et qui
comporte un chapitre dédié je le cite
haut à la gestion d'état sri c'est à
dire des déchets d'origine médicale avec
une responsabilités conférées aux
hôpitaux pigeons au centre de tout en
matière de traitement des déchets donc
on ya pensé mais merci de votre question
laurence cohen oui merci madame la
présidente merci monsieur le ministre
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
donc moi je vais revenir sur les
questions de logistique parce que
effectivement il semble que ce soit un
problème épineux dans notre pays ça a
été vrai pour les masses pour les tests
et on le sent encore aujourd'hui au
niveau de l'avion et c'est d'ailleurs à
mon sens le fait que le la logistique
publique d'état et était quand même
démantelé et pas par votre gouvernement
mais avant qui vous conduit sans doute à
faire appel à un cabinet de conseil de
stratégie un cabinet privé vous fait
appel donc à ce cabinet mckinsey c'est
l'un des plus grands du monde avec près
de 10 milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires et dont effectivement les
services sont quand même facture et il
faut lui dire 130000 euros la semaine
donc je voudrais savoir finalement sur
quel budget cet argent va être pris
c'est à dire est ce que ça va dépendre
du budget du ministère de la santé ou de
l'elysée directement ou bien est-ce que
ça va être pris sur le budget de la
sécurité sociale froid que c'est très
important que nous le sachions au niveau
de la commission des affaires sociales
et je vous en remercie par avance
c'est la triste le budget de financement
est pris sur le budget du ministère donc
le budget du ministère de la santé et
des solidarités de la santé certainement
pas sur le budget de la sécurité sociale
et je n'ose encore une fois je
revendique que nous soyons capables que
nous soyons capables de nous et de nous
épauler sur toutes les compétences ou
qu'elle existe il ya par exemple un
général qui est en charge de la
logistique au sein du ministère il
lieutenant-colonel qui y travaillent il
y a plusieurs dizaines de logisticiens
certains sont venus d'ailleurs nous
épauler bénévolement d'autres ont été
recrutés j'ai vraiment ça rassure envie
qu'un général la tête de logistique
parce que je vous rassure mais bien sûr
bien sûr nous faisons appel à toutes les
compétences ans qu'elle existe
heureusement nous en avons beaucoup dans
le secteur public je voudrais dire
pardon mais je n'en profite à chaque
fois mais je voudrais les remercier ces
personnes parce que derrière le mot
technostructure administration derrière
toutes ces personnes sont en fait ce
sont des milliers de personnes qui se
sentent parfois pointé du doigt alors
qu'elles consacrent absolument toute
leur énergie qu'avec elle travaille au
sein du ministère
en dehors du ministère dans une agence
régionale ou nationale ou qu'elle
travaille dans le secteur privé qu'elle
soit venu nous épauler ou qu il vient d
armes et autres ce sont des gens je vous
assure si vous veniez les voir avec moi
ce sont des gens qui travaillent en
permanence et qui travaillent en réseau
et qui travaille bien
le challenge est absolument immense le
chantier de logistique dans notre pays
est immense je dis pas que nous avons
toutes les compétences et que et que les
choses coule de source
effectivement et je ne suis pas sûr que
la france soit le pays le plus équipé à
la base en termes logistiques mais je
vous dis qu on a des ressources
absolument absolument admirable et ce
sont des gens qui parfois se sentent
incriminés quand il ya des critiques
bien davantage à dire que que le
politique lui même et qui ont besoin
qu'on les soutienne donc je dis à mes
équipes que je vais remercier que je les
soutiens
bernard bonne oui monsieur milices par
rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure effectivement moi je voudrais
poser la question des femmes 30%
je crois qu'il faut absolument
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce que vous
aviez nier ce que vous avez dit dans le
calendrier vaccinal qu'il faut optimiser
au maximum les doses qui sans donner aux
différentes personnes or les médias
comme le gouvernement du reste parle des
30% qui risque d'être perdu dans le
cadre de la vaccination est ce qu'il ne
serait pas possible dans tous les
centres qui seront nombreux de
vaccination de permettre lorsque
l'utilisation n'est pas totale des
flacons soir
parce qu' elle a trop soit parce que des
doses ne sont pas toutes utilisées de
permettre à des personnes ne permettent
à des personnes de venir
même sans critère d'âge d'autres choses
pour se faire vacciner profiter des
vaccins avant qu'il ne soit perdu je
remercie votre question ce n'est pas la
première fois que j'entends mais ce type
de questions me fait me fait penser on
pourrait le considérer que par a priori
nous manquerions de bon sens voit que
nous pourrions manqué de bon sens et que
les médecins les pharmaciens les
infirmiers pourrait manquer de bon sens
il n'y a pas besoin de consignes écrites
ou deux mots d'ordre pour que quelqu'un
ne jette pas à flacons dans lequel il
resterait une ou deux doses à la fin de
la journée de vaccination et qu'ils
vaccinent les personnes qui se trouvent
autour
nous les avons malgré tout écrit de ses
consignes monsieur le sénateur dans un
célèbre dans un guide devenu célèbre
pour bien rappeler notamment dans les
ehpad que s'il n'y a plus de candidats à
la vaccination qui répondent aux
critères et bien tout candidat
disponible sur place doit évidemment se
faire proposer le vaccin nous ne voulons
pas rejeter le taux de 30% qui est un
taux théorique de pertes liées au
transport à l'usagé etc
nous n'en sommes nous en sommes
aujourd'hui très loin je touche du bois
il nous reste de longues semaines nous
sommes à ce stade très très loin de ce
taux de pertes ce qui est une excellente
nouvelle puisque quelques unités taux de
pertes ce qui ce qui semble
effectivement très peu aujourd'hui
signe que 1 tout le monde progresse et
deux shoots on fait très attention à ce
bac 5 est un bien précieux
le problème c'est que la population soit
averti justement de la possibilité de se
faire vacciner il en soit là vous savez
on parle de une ou deux doses qu'ils
resteraient dans un flacon ouvert on ne
fait pas un appel population fin je me
vois mal faire un appel à la population
leur disant rôder autour de nepad à
15h06 jamais reste une ou deux doses
vous avez vous avez des soignants qui
sont âgés de moins de 50 ans vous avez
de la famille qui peut être présentes
vous avez l'animateur local de l'ehpad
enfin vous avez je vous assure qu'ils
trouvent il ya je n'ai aucune je n'ai
aucune remontée de soigner en me disant
on a fini notre journée de boulot on va
jeter 10 vaccins ce qu'on a trouvé
personne donc voilà ça se fait c'est en
marge c'est une toute petite fraction de
la vaccination mais évidemment nous ne
voulons pas jeter de doses de vaccins
madame pensait longe rouge s'explique
merci madame après la présidente
monsieur le ministre
tout d'abord je rappelais effectivement
le soutient la stratégie vaccinale qui
peut-être aussi est un facteur de
lenteur de la montée en charge
on vaccine d'abord les milliers d pad
sur le territoire vite dire que
effectivement on a vu l'accélération de
des publics prioritaires notamment des
aides à domicile qui a été très saluée
il reste cependant les bénévoles il me
semble des établissements médico sociaux
qui ne sont pas encore cité dans les
populations cibles
le dôme le demandent et qui
effectivement les acteurs associatifs
qui agissent auprès de ces publics
mon ma question porte sur l'accès au
vaccin
l'accès au vaccin qui est un marché
régulé 1 par l'union européenne vous en
avait parlé
la france reçoit donc son quota
générationnel sont des vaccins que nous
avons précommander que l'europe à
précommander dans le cadre des
informations régionales la semaine
dernière donnée auprès des élus il a été
mentionné que certains pays européens
ont retards logistiques peut-être
puisque nous libère enfin ont libéré des
quantités résiduelles
ces quantités je voudrais savoir
sont-elles réguler elle aussi par
l'europe selon les mêmes critères
générationnel et si ce n'est pas le cas
le parlement mais aussi le public doit
avoir accès aux contrats d'achats
directs français
si c'est le cas et à leurs conditions et
prix vous engagez vous monsieur le
ministre à la transparence sur ces
contrats comme le demandent par ailleurs
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
par la mise en place notamment c'est une
proposition d'un registre public des
contrats signés fût ce un contrôle a
posteriori
voilà vous l'avez compris monsieur le
ministre ces questions portent sur la
transparence et c'est un facteur de
confiance des élus et de la population
qui est dont dépend le succès de notre
stratégie vaccinale
madame la sénatrice lorsque la
commission européenne et ça lui arrive
de le faire et c'est tant mieux
doit passer de nouveaux contrats avec
des laboratoires pour lequel elle avait
déjà pré commander
aux la règle simple qu'ils s'appliquent
est la même c'est à dire que chaque pays
se voient proposer la possibilité de
commander des vaccins au prorata de sa
population au sein de l'europe
c'est une règle d'équité si jamais des
pays un ou plusieurs pays refuse
d'acquérir les doses qui leur correspond
alors ces doses peuvent être mises à
nouveau à répartition pour les pays qui
le souhaiterait et qu'il faudrait et qui
voudrait acheter
la france est extrêmement attentive vous
le dire la france est extrêmement
attentive à ce que chaque pays se voit
respecter et respecte lui-même cette
règle tacite importante d'équité au sein
de l'union européenne
cuisez moyens mais leur rendra oui enfin
si les contrats donc d'achat direct de
ccc quantité résiduelle est ce que c'est
mais contraste seront rendus publics et
où les lignes a pas de contrat d'achat
direct au sein de l'union européenne
les règles sont très claires ce sont
uniquement des marchés passés par la
commission européenne
et c'est la commission européenne
elle-même qui assurent le dispatching au
sein des pays de l'union européenne où
tout est transparent et votée par les
parlementaires européens en terme de
règles de fonctionnement
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
miss je vais être direct comme un ces
lettres dans la dans le gard à matière
de stratégie vaccinale qui décident
monsieur le ministre est ce que c'est le
politique
est-ce que c'est l'administration voire
la bureaucratie ou est ce que c'est
trente cinq citoyens qui sont tirés au
sort
la politique
finale est conduite par le ministère de
la santé sous la responsabilité du
premier ministre du présent arrêt public
la stratégie d'acquisition des vaccins
est conduite conjointement par agnès
pannier rue nash est la secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'industrie et par
le ministre secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre des affaires étrangères et de
l'europe clément bonne nous inspirons et
nous suivons les recommandations des
autorités scientifiques indépendantes en
toute transparence nous avons un comité
vaccinale moi je pense que nous sommes
bien outillé avec ces instances qui
fonctionne bien pour mener et conduire
une main une politique de stratégie
néanmoins il avait été question est
d'ailleurs ça va être une demande
je crois qu'ils étaient qui avaient été
relayées ici au sénat monsieur le
sénateur qu'il y ait de la citoyenneté
de l'intégration citoyenne de la
démocratie sanitaire et le conseil
économique social et environnemental
saisi s'était saisi de cette question là
et avait proposé qu'un tirage au sort de
citoyens soient réalisés qui permettent
de suivre la politique vaccinale qui
menait à ce stade je ne connais pas les
trente ou trente-cinq personnes ci
ressort je ne sais pas s'ils ont été
tirés au sort mais je vous redis comment
la compte de la conduite de la politique
vaccinale est réalisé dans notre pays et
j'ai l'honneur et la chance et le
privilège de venir rendre compte de
cette action à échenon réguliers devant
lé parlement c'est ma quatrième ou
cinquième intervention aujourd'hui
devant le parlement où devant des
commissions ou devant des réunions
d'élus je pense que c'est important et
en termes de transparence je crois que
nous avons rempli les critères vernis
guillotin merci à madame la présidente
jus de deux questions la première
concerne la définition des publics
prioritaires
donc j'ai bien compris la hiérarchie des
patients les plus âgés les plus fragiles
en ehpad aurait pas d' et les tranches
d'âge est-ce qu'il serait pas judicieux
puisque je pense qu'on a quand même
aujourd'hui un nombre de vaccins
suffisant me semble-t-il d'intégrer mais
assez rapidement les publics les plus
jeunes mais en fait des publics très
fragilisé je pense notamment aux
patients éventuellement immunodéprimés
patients greffés
voilà ce type de patients là est ce
qu'il pourrait pas réintégré cette liste
des patients prioritaire est la deuxième
question c'est plutôt sur les variant du
virus qui préoccupe tout le monde
aujourd'hui
pas seulement parce que le variant
angles et semble plus contagieux mais
aussi parce que nous ne pouvons pas
exclure à moyen ou long terme
revenu d'un virus dont la mutation
vendrait moins efficace voire pas
efficace la vaccination donc déjà sa
demande à une accélération vaccinale
pour éviter ce problème là et maintenant
que nous connaissons cette capacité de
mutation du virus j'aimerais savoir si
vous enfin si notre pays va se lancer et
va accélérer le séquençage afin de
dépister et dans le cas d'un dépistage
le cas échéant quelle va être la
politique vaccinale derrière s'il peut
permettre à madame la sénatrice de deux
très importantes questions vous
soulignez la première c'est
l'intégration parmi les publics
prioritaires d'une certaine partie de la
population
ces seuils qui d'entre nous n'ont pas 75
ans mais qui souffrent de maladies qui
les expose à un risque de formes graves
c'est le professeur alain fischer qui
est chargé de rédiger cette liste de
maladies de comorbidité comme on les
appelle particulièrement exposantes au
risque de formes graves et que nous
intégrerons et que nous ajouterons aux
personnes de 75 ans et plus qui pourront
bénéficier la vaccination à partir de
lundi prochain
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
français c'est une liste qui n'est pas
l'exhaustivité que certains lui
souhaiterait mais qui une liste qui se
fixe comme critère la rigueur
scientifique quant à l'exposition des
formes graves on peut imaginer qu'on y
trouvera des patients souffrant des mots
pâtit maligne ou de cancer au cours de
traitement par exemple vous avez posé la
question des greffes d'organes des
greffés d'organes qui sont évidemment au
coeur des préoccupations sanitaires
deuxième question sur le séquençage
oui sur le séquençage la france se
développe sous l'égide de frédéric vidal
ministre en charge de la recherche et de
l'innovation des plateformes uniforme
unifiée de séquençage génomique en lien
avec les cnrs du pasteur les ja chu et
laboratoires publics et privés de
manière à augmenter nos capacités de
séquençage génétique pour faire face à
la survenue de variants j'étais hier
avec le professeur lina hier soir assez
tard recevra bruno lina qui est un
éminent virologue et qui amenait sur les
journées de jeudi et vendredi dernier le
travail qui consiste à colliger des
milliers de tests pcr réaliser ces deux
jours-là en france et de les faire
passer sur ce qu'on appelle une
plateforme thermo fisher qui permet de
suspecter la présence à bari en anglais
et ensuite de procéder un séquençage
génétique en bonne et due forme des
classes suspecte ils nous disent
hier qu'il trouve à peu près 1% de
variants de nature d'origine anglaise
parmi les pcr positive en france avec
une disparités territoriales dispersion
territoriales qui fait qu'il n'ya pas de
région qui concentrerait de nombreux cas
c'est très intéressant très utile ça
permet de surveiller s'il ya une
croissance de ce variant et de vérifier
s'il devait apparaître des clusters donc
c'est une opération qui sera renouvelée
très régulièrement c'est-à-dire toutes
les 7 à 10 jours environ
chantal de seine ensuite ce sera victor
jasmin mais chantal de seine merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez répondu sur la no
calendrier vaccinal
je voudrais vous faire préciser votre
réponse sur le taux de protection du
vaccin est sûr une deuxième injection à
six semaines
quel est donc le taux de protection à
six semaines les scientifiques ne
semblent pas tous d'accord sur la
question
certains affirment que la protection
monte en puissance dans les trois
premières semaines pour atteindre un
palier et éventuellement redescendre
avant après par non et donc une deuxième
injection à six semaines ne permettrait
pas d'obtenir une immunité suffisante
je me suis fait l'écho encore une fois
de l'avis de l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament en charge des
autorisations de mise sur le marché des
médicaments et qui nous dit que si la
deuxième dose du vaccin fader devait
être différée à six semaines cela n'en
porterai pas de conséquence j'ai dit
tout à l'heure une erreur pardonnez moi
j'ai dit que j'avais saisi la haute
autorité de santé de la question aurait
été la haute autorité de santé se saisir
elle même de cette question à travers ce
qu'on appelle la setv qu'est la
commission technique de la vaccination
on a beaucoup d'autorités sanitaires et
scientifiques qui travaillent sur ces
questions là et donc nous verrons si
elle a fine et précise les choses et
j'ai parlé aussi de la vie de le m&a qui
va dans ce sens je n'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire que celui ci sauf à
dire que j'ai décidé que la deuxième
injection pour les personnes âgées en
ehpad ce serait à trois semaines et que
j'ai ouvert la possibilité que la
deuxième injection pour des personnes
par exemple tel que les soignants de 50
ans et plus puissent se faire entre 4 et
jusqu'à six semaines
si c'était
choisie si c'était le choix local ils
sont habilités à le faire là mêmes
encadre les règles de prescription par
des médecins donc on ne va pas sur
encadrer les règles de prescription par
rapport à ce que proposent les agences
sanitaires
si demain et je pense que j'aurais
bientôt des recommandations affiné
précisé par la haute autorité de santé
alors je reviendrai vers vous et je vous
dirais voilà vous voyez ce que nous dit
aujourd'hui la haute autorité de santé
sur quels fondements et voilà quelles
conclusions en tirer près bien victor
jasmin en visio corde mais il y en a
tous très bonne année à tous et eamonn
anime sur ministre
et bien je vous parle depuis la voie
loupe je voudrais seulement savoir
monsieur ministre lise et les
éventuelles clauses de non recours
est-ce qu'ils existent est ce que les
différentes firmes qui ont reçu les
autorisations de mise en 2011 sur le
marché ont bénéficié de ces clauses là
alors ils sont venus de l'est les
précisions une formation nécessaire je
remercie coordonnées m'en excuser mans
avec le son jour les clauses pour les
cours à l'école
excusez moi excusez moi c'est moi
excusez moi au cas où il y en aurait
parce que bon j'ai entendu dire qu'il y
en aurait une qui en avait alors je
voudrais avoir des précisions et des
informations concernant ces clauses
particulièrement avec les films qui ont
déjà reçu les autorisations de mise sur
le marché de leur verser oui non recours
contre le laboratoire
ah oui d'accord dont il n'ya pas d'un
corps des clauses limitation de
responsabilité et des visites en tout
cas pour les usagers et bien est-ce
qu'il y aura celle ci close parce qu'il
y avait évidemment des antilles qui
parle de ses coûts d'accord y compris
donc il n'y a pas de clause de non
responsabilité qui protégerait les
laboratoires on est dans le droit commun
savoir que ces laboratoires
commercialise un produit qui dev qui
souffre d'un défaut de fabrication ou de
biais et c'est le laboratoire en est
entièrement responsable
en revanche si quelqu'un doit présenter
un effet indésirable grave avec des
séquelles des conséquences ou tout autre
problème justifiant qu'il y est un
accompagnement médical voire une prise
en charge voire des indemnisations et
qu'il n'y a pas de faute du laboratoire
dans le sens où ce n'est pas la nature
du produit mais plutôt la réaction ce
qu'on appelle un aléa thérapeutique qui
peut intervenir c'est la solidarité
nationale via l'oniam qui est une caisse
qui existe d'ailleurs comme pour tous
les médicaments tous les vaccins et
toute intervention médicale ou
chirurgicale qui prend en charge et qui
dédommage et indemnise les patients
l'oniam pouvant se retourner d'ailleurs
dans de très rares cas contre le
professionnel de santé qui a effectué
l'acte par exemple s'il ya une faute
manifeste et non pas une erreur mais une
faute manifeste comme par exemple
quelqu'un qui ne sait pas même un
vecteur et cinq flacons au lieu d'une
dose dans ce cas là c'est évidemment pas
la solidarité nationale ya une faute
manifeste caractérisée mais si notre
système est protecteur pour les
soignants et il ne l'est pas pour les
laboratoires martel évrier on va on va
recommencer vraiment de questions encore
je suis désolé mais temps passe très
vite
martin lévriers pas tout le monde en
particulier à toulouse au ministre et à
travers vous à tous les personnels
soignants de france et tous les
administratifs qui effectivement sont
souvent pris pour des boucs émissaires
ce qui ne résout pas les problèmes
deux questions la première fut désolant
et bien de richard yung le sénateur des
français de l'étranger qui s'interroge
sur les orientations qui pourraient être
définies pour la vaccination des
français établis hors de france
est ce qu'il y a selon vous est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il y à déjà à travailler ces
sujets là où d'un jeu et je rebondis sur
cette question pour poser la même
question pour les étrangers établis en
france inquiète bon temps et procédures
françaises ou d'autres procédures
et enfin dernière question j'ai vu que
des parents de prise de rendez-vous
médical type autolib aille là où
d'autres ont été sélectionnés par l'état
pour la phase grand public
est-ce que trop d'informations ou trop
de possibilités ne risque pas de tuer
les possibilités et comment cela va être
organisé merci beaucoup
par exemple c'est celui qui gère les
carnets de commandes de 22 carnet de
rendez-vous pour l'allemagne notamment
berlin donc et c'est un acteur français
donc on a eu l'honneur on l'a mis dans
le dans le panel des acteurs mais n'est
pas tout seul ils sont trois et il y à
un système national uniforme pour les
pour les usagers ne verront pas la
différence puisque ça passe par un site
qui est le site sante.fr qui ce n'est
pas encore activée pour prendre
rendez-vous mais qui le sera d'ici à
jeudi pour les français de l'étranger
c'est comme pour toute prise en charge
et peuvent se faire vacciner localement
s'il ya des conventions entre la france
et les états dans lesquels ils résident
alors il peut y avoir une prise en
charge des frais et sinon ils peuvent se
faire vacciner en france il rentre dans
les mêmes conditions que n'importe quel
français vivant en france
je crois qu'ils avaient une troisième
question je sénateurs mais je l'ait
peut-être mangé les héros en france même
dispositif c'est inutile à l'étranger
résidant en france
et bien s'il a une sécurité sociale ou
une convention de sécurité sociale
il est pris en charge et en définitive
un étranger peut se faire vacciner sur
le sol français s'ils répondent aux
critères d'ouverture des fichiers
donnant droit à des soins au titre de
n'importe quelle soit madame ferrer
questions rapides
elle est où madame ferrer oui très vite
parce que ça va ça va être la dernière
est fait chuter sa mission ministre je
voulais revenir rapidement sur le rôle
et la place des élus locaux dans
l'organisation et le des commandes de la
campagne cette campagne de vaccination
pouvez vous nous dire comment vous les
avez associés et/ou consulté pour cette
organisation
ils sont très demandeurs vous l'avez dit
ils sont prêts à s'investir comme ils
l'ont fait depuis le début de l'épidémie
et vous savez comme nous qu'ils
connaissent parfaitement leur territoire
et leur population
comment peuvent-ils donc faire connaître
eux aussi leurs besoins et en
particulier je pense
dans mon département du calvados ont un
certain nombre déjà deux centres de
vaccination ont été mis en place mais il
n'y a entre guillemets comme on dit
familièrement un trou dans la raquette
car une commune de plus de 8000
habitants ne se voit pas mis en place ce
centre de vaccination et obligerait donc
les populations à faire 40 voire plus
kilomètres pour voir se faire vacciner
tout cela participe de la proximité et
du lien essentiel et du rôle extrêmement
important de des élus locaux
je vous remercie madame la sénatrice
comme j'en discute avec les élus locaux
régulièrement j'ai fait plusieurs
déplacements je vais faire je vais avoir
au moins trois centres de vaccination un
contre et trois élues distincts locaux
dans l'est dans les 48 prochaines heures
encore une fois on peut pas avoir un
centre de vaccination partout on veut 5
ou 600 de vaccination par département ce
qui assure comme un bon maillage si les
élus souhaitent organiser des transports
collectifs ou individuels vers des
centres ils peuvent le faire c'est des
élus souhaitent mobiliser les personnes
âgées isolées chez elles dont ils savent
qu'elles sont isolés et chez elle ils
peuvent tout à fait le faire si les élus
disposent de personnels de mairie à
mettre à disposition des centres ils
peuvent le faire et d'ailleurs ils le
font si les élus souhaitent participer à
promouvoir la vaccination auprès de la
population de leur commune ils peuvent
le faire ils sont même invités et
inciter à le faire si les élus
souhaitent identifier des soignants ou
toutes ressources permettant d'enrichir
la campagne vaccinale et d'y participer
activement ils peuvent le faire les élus
locaux participent aux cellules
départementales de coordination de mise
en place de la vaccination on avec les
préfets les ars les élus locaux ont un
rôle fondamental important est pour
l'instant partout où je suis allé il le
prenait à bras le corps partout dans
chaque centre où je suis allé il y avait
un maire qui étaient présents des élus
ses adjoints qui participent qui
organise qui font la promotion du centre
je crois que c'est encore une fois de ce
fourmillement collectif au delà de
toutes les étiquettes pour ça que je
souhaite vraiment que sur cette campagne
vaccinale au delà des critiques qui
peuvent être tout à fait légitime ou des
des encouragements quelle que soit leur
forme à faire plus vite mieux ou
différemment
je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit soudée
comme jamais dans ce pays il faut qu'on
soit soudée comme jamais nous avons un
enjeu de la confiance majeure qui est
devant nous nous ne pouvons pas être un
pays dans lequel le taux d'adhésion à la
vaccination serait plus faible
qu'ailleurs et je n'y crois pas une
seconde
parce que si les français sont critiques
si les français s'interrogent si les
français réfléchissent avant d'agir en
définitive les français font le bon
choix
eh bien nous devons leur donner
confiance d accompagner vers ce bon
choix et mettre en place
chacun à notre place chacun avec nos
compétences nos rôles nos
responsabilités nos atouts ce qui doit
procéder d'une grande campagne de
vaccination pour notre pays je vous
remercie
voilà nous avions ce temps très
contraint c'est compliqué nous étions
nombreux encore beaucoup de collègues
qui souhaitait poser les questions des
questions monsieur iacovelli je suis
d'accord mais enfin monsieur le ministre
était hors de question que pose une
question
c'est pas vrai l'écouté pas vrai parce
que j'ai essayé justement de faire
tourner dans l'ordre et ce n'est pas moi
qui ai fixé une heure de de l'audition
donc vous vous arrangez avec monsieur le
ministre
puisque vous êtes si vous permettez je
vais aller à la rencontre des directions
des pharmaciens des médecins des 100
hôpitaux pivot ainsi que de tous les
directeurs généraux des ars il y aura
également de le croire les préfets pour
continuer de travailler avec eux comme
je le fais toutes les semaines
néanmoins je reste à disposition du
parlement et en particulier du sénat je
serai je crois demain pour la séance de
questions au gouvernement s'il y avait
des questions complémentaires et si vous
souhaitez nous adresser des questions il
y à ma collaboratrice ma conseillère en
charge des affaires parlementaires que
chacun connaît ici qui me transmettre à
vos questions et/ou à mon équipe et je
me fais fort d'y répondre avec 48 heures
voilà donc ce que je vous propose pour
ceux qui n'ont pas posé de question
c'est de me les adresser celle que vous
souhaitiez posez moi j'avais aussi
beaucoup de questions qui ont été
données j'ai essayé de faire parler en
effet en ne respectant pas forcément
l'or mais pour que tous les groupes
s'exprime je suis vraiment désolé mais
c'est un temps très contraint merci
monsieur le ministre pour des réponses
précises à des questions précises
sachez que nous ne sommes pas dans la
polémique
[Musique]